dunder-mifflin this is Pam Michael
what's wrong okay wait wait wait wait
Michael do you need me to call an
ambulance
okay way to say I thought you said that
you were hurt hey whoa Michael okay
Jim just say again really loudly what
happened you burned your foot on a
foreman mill I enjoy having breakfast in
bed I like waking up to the smell of
bacon sue me
and since I don't have a butler I have
to do it myself so most nights before I
go to bed I will lay six strips of bacon
out on my George Foreman grill then I go
to sleep when I wake up I plug in the
grill I go back to sleep again then I
wake up to the smell of crackling bacon
it is delicious it's good for me it's a
perfect way to start the day today I got
up I stepped onto the grill and I
clamped down on my foot that's it I
don't see what's so hard to believe
about that
do you want to know how I actually heard
- yes I was look whooping Kevin and I
attend a class for fitness and for fun
you know my god I've mastered all the
moves the pizza toss the tornado the
Scorpion the oopsie doodle why are you
telling me this because no one will ever
believe you know hey cousin heard you
having money problems no you didn't
listen I got the answer you declare
bankruptcy all your problems go away how
would that help Creed in monopoly you go
bankrupt you lose you don't go by
monopoly man that game is nuts
nobody just picks up
get-out-of-jail-free cards those things
cost thousands that is a good point
bankruptcy Michael is nature's do-over
it's a fresh start it's a clean slate
like the witness protection program
excited oh I've always wanted to be in
the witness protection program fresh
start no debts no baggage far I got my
name picked out Lord Rupert Everton I
made a shipping merchant who raises
fancy dogs that's the life
I declare bankruptcy it's 9:00 a.m. why
is no one working Amy Santiago is a few
minutes late and we're all trying to
guess why I like to play I'd say she's
in line at the bank this is fun it is
fun but you're all wrong
she clearly slipped through a subway
grate and is having terrible sex with a
mole man
there she is Amy where have you been
we've been worried sick do you care to
explain yourself
I'm just 70 seconds late it's not a big
deal don't worry about it Santiago you
will tell us and you will tell us now
there's a problem at the bank oh yes it
is true I Michael Scott I'm signing up
with an online dating service thousands
of people have done it and I am going to
do it I need a username and I have a
great one little kid lover that way
people will know exactly where my
priorities are at jackpot let's do this
and how am I supposed to get all the way
up there gracefully Phil recruited me to
sell these cards and now I am recruiting
you who was this guy again don't worry
about Phil he drives a Corvette he is
doing just fine
okay calling cards are the wave of the
future these things sell themselves
who's this calling cards anyway you know
what that's a nice attitude Ryan I'm
just helping you invest in your future
my friend it sounds like a
get-rich-quick scheme yes
thank you you will get rich quick we all
will can you lose a lot of money on that
other investment that one from the email
you know what Toby when the son of the
deposed King of Nigeria emails you
directly asking for help you helped his
father ran the freaking country okay all
right so raise your hand if you want to
get rich all right no how is this
a pyramid scheme all right let me
explain I get phil has recruited me and
another guy now we are getting three
people each the more people to get
involved the more people who are
investing the more money we're all gonna
make it's not a pyramid scheme it is a
it's not even a scheme per se it's
I have to go make a call the math thing
isn't the problem night shifts keeping
you and Kevin apart you two just need a
bone
just hate it I said you two need a bone
Oh dare you detective Diaz I am your
superior officer Oh
what happens in my bedroom detective is
none of your business don't ever speak
to me like that again why should you
that dude is pent up no he knows
problem solved god no God please no no
no I've never been more proud of you for
anything in your life
I mean I've solved a lot of cases for
you and yet crime is continued on
testkit
okay I'll be putting them everywhere and
please don't throw these out this is a
radon test kit please don't throw these
out see them all over the office
Toby has been leaving radon kits
everywhere like he owns the place the
first time I threw mine away I thought
it was an ant trap but I figured I'd
rather live with ants and with his
creepy little disk second time I thought
it was one of those you know the things
you turn over and moves like a cow thing
but upon closer examination it was
another ant trap so I threw it away and
the third time I did it out of spite
you're kidding me God you say right on a
silent but deadly and then you expect me
not to make farting noises with my mouth
what is this you know we're not gonna
die of radon we're gonna die boredom
yeah
right and if I had a gun with two
bullets and I was in a room with hitler
bin Laden and Toby I would shoot Toby
twice okay all right really funny and
you went too far
I would kill bin Laden and then Toby no
it's still okay geniuses how would you
do it sergeant I'd like you to meet
Richard and Dan they are puppies very
cute sir
maybe you twins would like some little
furry friends I'm sorry sir but that's
impossible
with the twins learning how to walk
chaos reigns at the Jeffords household I
can't let those innocent pups into that
madhouse Terry won't do you like that I
understand just know you have
disappointed oh that's cold sir what's
wrong Michael
gum in my hair you do this just stinks
don't touch it please don't touch it you
got a ton of dandruff okay let me be how
do you get going here I was walking in
and I noticed something shiny under
Stanley's car and I got under see what
it was and I messed up my hair all for a
stupid piece of tinfoil but best case
scenario you thought it was a corner
kill me right now we have peanut butter
in the kitchen I don't feel like peanut
butter give me an ice-cream sandwich oh
not for you it's for your hair and it is
9:00 a.m.
no Dwight not the good peanut butter
people are gonna get mad hey hey hey
this is my hair we're talking about
smells good tastes good too Oh Donna
that's disgusting Wow a lot of calories
well just don't leave it on too long
keep massaging please I'm tired of
politics
let's get that Punk blood so this is
amazing of course we have no idea where
he is but I love where your head's at
yep no family maybe there was a
girlfriend or someone he worked with at
the coffee shop at the coffee shop why
would someone who knows they have 21
million dollars coming take a
minimum-wage job because he needed
access to that building because that's
where the money's hidden
all right we gotta get there quick maybe
we should take the chopper chopper death
blade Sidewinder
it's go time Roger that wet blanket snow
from now on call me velvet
you